- Hi everyone, welcome to
the Homeroom live stream.
I'm very excited about the
conversation we're about to have,
but before we jump into that,
I'll make a couple of my
standard announcements.
First of all, just a
reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself,
so if you're in a position
to do so, please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
I also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations
who've really stepped up
when they realized that Khan Academy
was running at a deficit
even before the COVID crisis.
And during the crisis,
as you could imagine,
our traffic is almost 300% of normal,
our registrations are 10 X of normal,
we're trying to accelerate
a bunch of content
and programs so special
thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly,
Novartis and the Amgen Foundation,
and many other supporters
who have allowed Khan Academy
to be in a position to
serve a lot of folks
in this time of need and beyond.
I also wanna make sure everyone
knows, if you wanna listen
to these conversations, maybe in the car
or some other place,
you can get the Homeroom
with Sal the Podcast,
and you can find it a place where
you can find podcasts, I believe.
So with that, I'm really excited
to introduce our guests, John King.
John, great to have you.
- Glad to be here, thanks for inviting me.
- It's a real honor.
- John is, so you've served
as secretary of education
under President Obama,
you're the president and CEO
of The Education Trust.
There's so much I wanna talk to you about,
but before just so everyone
kind of really understands
the work that you do now.
What does The Education Trust do?
What is your focus?
- Sure. We're an education
civil rights organization.
So we work to ensure equitable access
to educational opportunity,
particularly for low income
students and students of color.
And I wanna encourage everyone,
given that now what you know about John,
put your questions on
YouTube and Facebook,
and we have team members
who will surface it
to myself and John over the
course of this conversation.
So John, maybe a good place to start,
given both your work in
the Obama administration
and the work that you do
now, how are you viewing
the crisis, I'd argue we're
facing in education right now?
Around the school closures,
how do you think it's going to play out?
What do you think we should be doing?
- Yeah, well, we're in
a disastrous situation,
because the country is in
a disastrous situation.
The federal government really failed
to manage the pandemic
based on the science.
We still don't have a
coherent national strategy
around rapid results testing,
around contact tracing,
around effective quarantine,
around mask wearing,
and other public health guidelines.
So in the absence of a
coherent national strategy,
we're left in a situation where schools
are bearing the brunt of the consequences.
And superintendents school boards
are an impossible situation
of trying to figure out
how to serve kids in a context
where there's tremendous
community spread of COVID-19.
The reality is many places will have to be
a distance or a best
hybrid, and we're doing that
in a context where we still
have this huge digital divide.
I mean, I don't have to tell you,
the Pew study shows 79% of white families
have reliable internet
access, 66% of black families,
61% of Latino families.
The school house door is
literally barred for students
because they don't have the internet.
We have gaps in access to devices,
we have gaps in access to
professional development
and support for teachers
around doing distance learning well.
Well resourced districts
have a ton of support
under resourced districts
disproportionally serving
low income students
and students of color
don't have those supports
for teachers, and we see those
consequences playing out.
Now, the last thing I'd mentioned is,
there's a real socio emotional
toll to school closure.
School is the place where kids
and adults build critically
important relationships.
I was a kid, my life was saved
by my relationships at school.
My mom passed when I was
eight. my dad when I was 12,
the thing that saved
me was the reliability,
the consistency of school.
And so my heart breaks for kids,
this spring were isolated in
homes where there was abuse
or domestic violence, or just the trauma
of COVID-19 health issues
or COVID-19 economic issues.
And now we go into a new school
year, where are we gonna see
those same socio-emotional challenges.
So we're in a tough spot
as a education sector.
- And if you were sitting in your old job
as secretary of education
right now, and obviously
what you just described
is absolutely true.
Ideally, we would have
really solid contact tracing
and testing, et cetera, et cetera.
But given where we are now,
what would you be doing
as sexual education?
Some would argue that,
there's only so many levels
at the federal level from
an education point of view,
but what levels are there?
- Yeah, well, really three things.
One is, the secretary
of education department
should be fighting for
resources for schools.
If the federal government
doesn't step forward
with significant stimulus dollars,
school districts gonna
end up making layoffs
at this critical time.
If there aren't stimulus dollars,
we can't address the
digital divide issues.
There's a proposal in Congress, $4 billion
to expand that E-rate programs,
so that schools can
help families get access
to the internet.
We should do that, we need
Congress to step up in that way,
and we need the secretary
of education to be fighting
for resources, for schools and
for our most vulnerable kids,
that's one.
Two, we need to lift up best practices,
what are great examples
of people doing distance
and hybrid well?
What does that look like?
The secretary has an
incredible bully pulpit
and could be sharing those
models from around the country,
to be lifting up districts
like the Phoenix Union
School District in Arizona
that has every student, every day campaign
where an adult from the school district
is in touch with every kid every day,
just to make sure
they're checking on them,
seeing if they need food or a WiFi hotspot
or help with math.
And then the third piece is
a guidance around navigating
some of these public
health considerations.
What should school
districts be thinking about,
rates of community spread?
And when should they make decisions
about opening or closing?
What should they do when there's a case
within a school building?
How many cases should
they see before they make
the decision to close back up?
School districts need
guidance on these things.
We have 13,000 school districts
each making these decisions on their own
with very little help from
the federal government
- And taking those one by
one, your first point about
the funding situation or at least trying
to close the digital
divide, giving access,
this feels like something
that's beyond politics,
it feels like it's a no
brainer, we're putting
a trillion dollars into each
of these rounds of stimulus.
Is there a counter argument?
Or are people just reticent to, I mean,
it seems like a small
percentage, not even a percentage
of the amount of stimulus
to get everyone access.
- Yeah, I mean, I think, as always happens
when there's an economic
crisis, there are people
who make a, well if you'll forgive this,
social studies teacher
reference, there are people
who make the Hoover
argument, we have to do less,
we can help people.
I think that's exactly
wrong, this is an FDR moment.
We should think about internet access
the way we thought about
electricity in the new deal.
And we have the Tennessee
Valley authority,
we have this massive national commitment
to make sure people had electricity
because you need it to operate
in the 20th century economy.
Well, now we need the internet to operate
in the 21st century economy.
It's how kids go to school,
but it's also how higher
ed students go to college,
it's how folks can get access to benefits,
it's how you look for a job today.
We really could be doing
more on this front,
but again, there are folks who wanna say,
"Well, because of the
financial crisis from COVID,
we just have to give
up on our aspirations."
I think that's exactly wrong.
- It makes a ton of sense.
I mean, part of that makes total sense
is that we shouldn't
(laughs) to be giving up.
- Honestly.
- On your second point about guidance.
I mean, that is something
that I feel as well,
that if people just had some direction
on what solid distance
learning can look like
or hybrid learning looks
like, that in and of itself.
We're trying to do what we can
given what limited voice we have.
That example you mentioned
in Phoenix is fascinating,
I'm actually surprised I
hadn't heard of that yet.
What other best practices
for any educators out there listening,
or any parents who are maybe in a position
to help influence what
their schools are doing,
what best practices have you been seeing
that you think need more amplification?
- Yeah, well, I'm so grateful
for what you are doing,
and you are doing and
what your team is doing
to try to make resources
available, that's critical.
Some things we're seeing,
Baltimore city for example,
is doing this project
where in some schools
they're having their
strongest teacher deliver
the sort of full class lesson
while the other teachers play more
of tutoring and support role for students.
I think there's an opportunity
here for creative staffing,
where people can play different roles
and you sort of leverage people's talents.
We ought to be doing more
of that in this moment.
School districts are
being very intentional
about the supports kids need
to do asynchronous work well.
And you know this from your
work, there are a set of skills
around setting goals, managing your time,
asking for help and
feedback when you need it,
acting on that feedback when you get it.
Those kinds of independent learning skills
are not necessarily something
that every classroom
has cultivated pre-COVID.
And so an intentionality around teaching
those student agency
skills is really important,
that's something that a
network of schools called LEAP,
is working on in Chicago for example.
There's the opportunity
to sort of emphasize relational work.
And this is a real
challenge, but kids need,
relationships with peers,
and so you've been thinking
about something small, like
how do we use breakout rooms
in Zoom so that kids are
working on projects together?
How do we make this an
opportunity for connectedness
rather than isolation for students?
Some school districts
are doing a better job,
trying to think about
how do we create projects
that kids are working on
and keep them engaged?
It is not enough to just
say we're gonna do exactly
what we used to do, just do it on Zoom.
That is not a effective
strategy for distance learning.
You've got to say, "How do we
use these new technology tools
to make learning engaging,
and to help support students
in their social development,
as well as their academic development."
- Couldn't agree more, a lot
of what we talk about is,
ironically distance
learning for a lot of kids,
their main connection to
socialization right now.
So it's not just about
the academic standards,
we've got to make some way
for kids to get connected.
I have a really fascinating
question from the YouTube,
Susanna Garcia Dominguez is saying,
"In light of the pandemic, what
rules need to be rewritten?"
Is there a moment here where
maybe there are some constraints,
maybe some rules regulations
that exist for good reason,
but maybe are slowing
down a rapid response
that we could loosen temporarily?
- Yeah, I mean, look,
we certainly, I think,
need to think flexibly
about school schedules
to make hybrid work,
to make distance work,
to create opportunities for students
to have a healthy
relationship to technology.
And we can't expect a first grader
to be in front of Zoom
for eight hours, right?
So we're gonna have to think
differently about the schedule,
we're gonna have to think differently
about how we engage parents,
parents are gonna have to
have a much larger role
in a distance learning context.
And so we're not gonna be
able to get by with just
the twice a year parent teacher a night,
we're gonna need regular
communication with families
so that they understand how to
support their kids learning.
We're gonna need to maybe
start to think about
a more competency based
model, where when students
are ready to move on to
the next level of work,
we allow that to happen.
I think about the Northern
Virginia Community College,
in Virginia, which this summer
offered every high school,
junior and senior in their
region, the opportunity
to take a college course for credit.
Senior year is not always well
used in every high school,
and so let's, let's get
students into college courses,
let's accelerate their
progress where we can.
And then as I mentioned, some flexibility
around staffing roles,
thinking differently
about how we use teacher's time,
if someone's an amazing presenter
of lessons, that's great,
but maybe someone else is better
at the one on one small
group support for students,
and let's deploy people
a little bit differently.
That's gonna require creative scheduling
and creative staff management.
- Now, I love those ideas,
and one of the things
that we've actually worked
with Long Beach School District
in Southern California,
it's this project, it's actually
outside of Khan Academy,
it's called Schoolhouse.world,
where there's one version
in a school district where
any teacher can work,
do group tutoring
sessions or group classes
with any student in the whole district.
So it seems to rhyme a little
bit with what you described,
but I really like what you talked about,
which is a division of labor
a little bit, where yeah,
there's the lecture, get
the best lecturer to do it,
but then get all the other
teachers really in that,
I would say the more important work
of that human to human
connection, that tutoring,
that unblocking.
I'm curious, I think we've
been talking about ideals,
which it sounds like
we're very aligned on,
how do you, it is going to
play out over the coming year?
What could be the damage?
What's gonna need to happen,
let's say nine months from now,
a year from now, when things get
to a little bit more normal?
- Yeah, well, we're certainly
gonna need to make up ground.
I mean, the reality is, you know this,
because of digital divide,
we have school districts
where a quarter of their kids
ain't participated at all,
last spring didn't log
in, and that's a disaster.
McKinsey did a study recently suggesting
that the average learning
loss or unfinished learning
would be seven months, nine
months for Latino students,
10 months for African American students.
So we're gonna have ground
that we need to make up,
that means when we get
back to bricks and mortar
and hopefully move past COVID,
we're gonna need to think
about extending the school day,
extending the school year.
We're gonna need to think
about high dosage tutoring,
which has a very strong evidence base.
There's a proposal in
Congress from Senator Coons
to double the AmeriCorps
program so that we could match,
let's say, recent college grads
with students to do intensive tutoring.
I think that makes a ton
of sense and is very smart.
The UK and the Netherlands
are also thinking about
a national tutoring core kind of effort.
So we'll need that academic support.
We'll also need to address
some of the socio-emotional impact.
I think we're going to
need more investment
in school counselors,
school social workers,
mental health services
for kids and for families.
We've done polling at the education trust
showing just very, very high
stress levels among parents,
particularly low income parents,
particularly parents of
students with disabilities
who are sometimes struggling to provide
the supports that kids need at home.
So we're gonna need to kind
of make up for lost time,
and some of the harm that's
come from this COVID crisis.
- Do you think that's doable?
Let's say we were to shift
from a Hoover mindset
to this FDR mindset that
you've been talking about,
is that doable at the federal level?
Or does it have to happen
at the state or local level?
- Well, we certainly
need federal investment,
we think that it's gonna
take at least $175 billion
just to prevent cuts in school districts.
But then on top of that,
we're in need of investment
in this tutoring effort
and extended learning time,
socio-emotional support, but
then we gonna need leadership
at the state level, the local level
and the school building level.
For folks to say, it's not just enough
to go back to business as usual,
we've got to make up for
the impact of COVID on kids.
And we've got acknowledged
that we had disparities,
big disparities, big inequities,
particularly around race
and income before COVID.
So going back to normal
is not good enough,
we actually need to
define a more equitable,
more just future,
and that will require
leadership at every level.
- And do you think there could
be any silver linings here,
that because of the
crisis, certain elements
are getting accelerated.
I mean, you talked about some good ideas,
that sound like good ideas in any context.
Do you think those things will last?
Do you think we'll come out
of this better and some ways?
- With the right leadership,
I think that's possible.
You know, some things I hope will stick.
One is, I think people
have seen that technology
can create access to opportunity
that kids couldn't access before.
So, we have high schools
where there are very few
AP classes for example,
but we know colleges look
for those AP courses,
we know they are often giving kids
an opportunity to get college credits
that make college more affordable.
But now if you're in a
high needs rural community,
you didn't have AP classes in your school,
but now you see through technology,
you can actually have a
distance learning AP experience.
Hopefully we will close the
advanced coursework divide
between some of our
schools coming out of this.
I think parents and teachers
have had to collaborate
in ways that I hope will stick.
The parents have gotten a window
into their kids' learning experience,
and teachers have gotten into a habit
of more communication with parents,
at least in some districts,
hopefully that continues.
And then I mentioned this
issue of student agency.
Students can do really cool stuff
when given the freedom
and opportunity to do it.
So as folks have had to move
from maybe a teacher centric model
to a model that blends the
synchronous and asynchronous,
they've gotten to see that,
"Oh, I can ask students
to do this research project
on how other countries
are grappling with COVID, and
kids do this amazing work.
Well, now let me shift my class
so there's more student agency,
more opportunity for students
to define their learning goals
and work with their peers to produce
a collaborative project."
So I think we could see
some positive benefits,
but first we need the kind
of leadership to step up
and get the resources and deal
with the immediate crisis.
- Now, that's super helpful.
In the time we have left, we
have a lot of young people
who watch this, and I think
it's always interesting
when we get high profile
guests like yourself.
To just understand your journey,
I mean, you started off,
you actually mentioned a few
things that I did not know
that it sounds like you got,
the early stages of your life
with your parents passing away,
it sounds like a pretty hard start.
I'd love to know kind of your arc,
like how did you go from there?
What was the context like
to eventually becoming
secretary of education?
- Yeah, well school as I
said, really saved my life.
Both of my parents were teachers
in the New York City public schools.
My mom passed when I was
eight, October 4th grade.
I lived with my dad, my dad was quite sick
with undiagnosed ulcers,
so is scary and lonely and unstable.
But school was amazing,
I had an amazing teacher in
fourth, fifth, sixth grade,
we did all these creative
projects, we did productions
of a Midsummer Night's Dream,
Shakespeare in elementary school,
we went to the museum and the ballet,
and it just exposed us
to this whole world
beyond Canarsie Brooklyn.
And that made a huge difference for me,
because I could be a kid in his classroom
and I couldn't at home.
My dad passed when I was 12,
and I moved around different schools,
different family members,
but it was always teachers
who gave me a sense of hope and purpose.
But like many young people
who've experienced trauma,
by the time I was in high school,
I was getting in a lot of trouble,
and I actually got kicked
out of high school.
The first US secretary of education,
I've been kicked out of high school.
But I was very fortunate
that there were teachers
and a school counselor
and some family members
who some more hope and potential in me
than I could see in myself, and
they gave me a second chance
and they invested in me,
and helped me get my life back on track.
And I ended up, had an opportunity to go
to Harvard for college,
and there I got involved
in public service,
volunteering, working with young people.
I always encourage high
school students conscience
to think about service.
How can you share the
blessings you have with others?
And so I got involved in
tutoring programs, summer camps
while in college, and that
showed me how fulfilling
it could be to try to be
the kind of difference in kids' lives
that teachers were for me.
- I'm curious.
- And so then I became
a high school social studies teacher.
- I mean, something you
mentioned which was fascinating
and as much as you're willing to share.
You got kicked out or almost
got kicked out of high school,
and then it sounds like a few years later
you ended up going to Harvard.
I'd love to double click on that.
I mean, as much as you want to share.
- Yeah.
- Where was your mind, or
if you're willing to share,
why were you might've gotten kicked out,
and then how was that turned around?
Cause I think so many kids are on that.
- Sure, well you know, I was very angry
as a teenager, angry at adults.
I mean, it may be irrational,
but I was angry at my parents,
angry at the things I
went through as a kid,
angry at adults in my family
who I felt like didn't step in.
And I think now in retrospect, I realized,
I didn't really know the scope
of what it was like at home,
and it was just my dad and me.
I mean, when my dad
was quite sick, I mean,
our house was crazy, I had
to figure out how to get food
in our house, how to
keep our household going,
and I thought someone
should have stepped in
and they didn't, and so I
was very angry about that.
And I was angry about just rules.
I've been on my own since I was eight,
I didn't want anyone
telling me what to do,
so when I got kicked out,
I thought my life was over,
I thought, well now, I won't
be able to go to college,
I won't be able to do anything.
But I'd always done well academically,
I mean, the irony was,
I'd always been really
passionate about learning.
And so really a school
counselor convinced me,
"You gotta make the case
that you have learned
from the choices you've made,
you've learned from these experiences
and you're ready to make
your life different."
And so I actually had to
write two college essays,
the regular essay, and then there's
a special essay you write
if you've been kicked out of high school,
and you have to explain what happened,
and what its impact was on you.
And I was very lucky that,
college admissions officers
were willing to take a chance on me,
and were willing to see that I had learned
from the mistakes I've made
and wanted to be different
and contribute in a different way.
- Wow, and so, I mean,
that's a fascinating story,
I think it'll be inspiring
for a lot of kids.
You know, I was the lead
singer of Heavy Metal Band,
so I understand a little
bit of that teenage anger.
But you were even tougher circumstances,
but I interrupted you, you were going,
upon graduation, how did you go from there
to a career and education
and eventually a secretary of education?
- Yeah, so it really was,
the public service experience
as an undergrad at Harvard, I
spent a lot of time in Boston,
in public housing development
where I ran afterschool
and summer programs.
And just got passionate about how,
I mean, just like you, right?
Just like your story, right/
There's something so fulfilling
about helping young people learn
and feel successful and feel empowered.
And so I love that, and so
that drew me to teaching.
And so first I was a high
school social studies teacher
in the same neighborhood
where I'd volunteered
as an undergrad in Boston.
And then I became a
middle school principal,
and I loved the work day
to day with students,
but I also wanted to think
about how do we move policy
so that we create more
opportunity for kids.
And that's what drew me ultimately
to working at the state level
and then at the federal level,
and having the chance to become secretary.
And it was such a privilege
to be a part of the Obama administration,
President Obama and Mrs.
Obama just so passionate
about education and the different schools
can make in kids' lives.
Mrs. Obama has this really powerful story
as a first generation college student.
She still committed significant time
to working on education issues.
She has an initiative called Reach Higher
that I'm involved in,
it's about helping high
school students think about
their post-secondary plans.
President Obama is still
involved in My Brother's Keeper,
which is focused on supports
for boys and young men of color.
So their depth of commitment,
it just was a pleasure
to work with them and to be
a part of the administration.
And now at Ed Trust,
I have the opportunity
to be an advocate and sort of join arms
with other civil rights
organizations with parents,
with educators, with students
to demand something better.
And we really have
these two pandemics now.
We've got a pandemic of
COVID-19, but we're also having
an important national conversation
about the pandemic of systemic racism
that has been a part of our
country from the beginning.
And so it's inspiring to
be a part of a movement
to make real change, to
make our society more just.
- Now, and your life arc is
inspiring on a lot of levels.
There's a really fascinating question,
maybe this is a good question
to end on, is from Facebook,
Marchelle Davis says, "As
parents, what should we be asking
or demanding of local education leaders?"
You mentioned there are
have a lot more agency now,
how can they drive what's
right for their children?
- Yeah, it's a great question.
We have a lot of
resources on this question
that interest that org, but
a few quick observations.
One is, to have a sense
of where your kids are,
to understand are they on
grade level or are they behind?
They need additional support?
How are they doing in math and reading
and science and social studies?
So an understanding of where
your kids are is critical.
You should be, uh, alongside your child
demanding real engagement in learning,
it is not enough to just have
a kid sit in front of Zoom
for hours while folks talk at them.
And so you want to be
demanded that your kids
are really engaged,
that they're getting
interesting assignments,
that they're reading interesting books,
that they're having
conversations with their teacher
with peers, they should be having
a real learning experience,
and we know that distance
learning it's challenging,
but it is possible to
have that real engagement.
And then the third piece
is that the socio-emotional
dimension and the creative dimension.
Yes, we got to focus on kids' academics,
but they also need to have relationships
with peers and teachers.
That morning meeting and elementary school
where the teacher just
checks in with every kid,
and they get to see their peers,
that can for some kids be
the best part of the day.
So we have to make sure
those socio-emotional
supports are in place.
We have to make sure that
there's creative time.
We still need the arts,
and we can subdue the
arts through distance.
We can still create opportunities
for students to paint,
to draw, to make music, to make
videos of their own, right?
We should be cultivating
that creative side
even as we try to try to grapple
with making distance learning work.
So I hope that parents are really pushing
their school districts to
deliver, especially in communities
that have been underserved.
We all have a moral responsibility
to make sure that every kid gets
a high quality education,
regardless of race,
regardless of income,
regardless of zip code.
- Now, couldn't agree more.
Well, thank you so much for
joining for this conversation.
I hope this is the first
of many conversations,
I hope we can also collaborate
on the Ed Trust Khan
Academy side of things,
but this is a real
honor, thank you so much.
- Thanks for the conversation.
Thanks for all you're doing.
- Awesome, well thanks
everyone for joining,
as you see another
fascinating conversation,
the time always goes by much
faster than I expect it to do
when we're enthralled
and getting some really
interesting wisdom.
But with that, encourage
everyone stay safe.
Reminders that the school
year is starting up,
go to Khan Academy, we have get ready
for grade level courses.
As Secretary King had
alluded to, these are ways
to identify where your kids are.
And if they're ready for grade level,
if they need to fill in some
gaps, they can obviously learn
at their own time piece on Khan Academy.
I also encourage folks to
go to Schoolhouse.world
which is the side project that I'm doing
with a ton of volunteers.
Ironically, we heard
Secretary King talk about
how important tutoring can be.
Ironically, at Shoolhouse.world,
we have a lot of really great tutors
who are waiting to tutor
you or your children
or someone else's
children, I guess, as well.
So go there, there's a lot
of capacity for what I think
could be really, really
compelling experiences
for a lot of young people,
where not only will you get
more support above and
beyond what you already get
from Khan Academy, but you
can also get some interaction
with folks really around the world,
which I think is pretty
cool in a safe environment.
So thanks everyone for joining,
and I'll see you, I
believe in a day or two,
where we're gonna do and ask me anything.
Oh, sorry, no, this is
Wednesday, tomorrow,
we're gonna have
Representative Karen Bass,
super exciting, so please
join us for that tomorrow.
See everyone later.
(upbeat music)